She's on about calcium in your blood, that has to do with bone cancer.
That does.
Yes, if you have high levels of calcium, that is, can be an indication of osteolytic activity
being bold as being broken down.
Since my anesthetic is there, should I be checking that?
That's something that should be done pretty regularly by your doctor is just calcium levels.
Well, honestly, I'm just doctoring with you mostly.
Okay, so what does a lot of, will you talk about your lab instead?
Okay, we had to get my D3 measures.
So I go this Monday to the traditional doctor and he's going to put me traditional totally.
But I'm just going to say yes, like a bubble head, yes, yes, yes.
And then I have the test, the cyrox test coming into you.
Okay, are you going next Monday, you said?
The 28, yeah.
Okay, so then ask them to do blood calcium levels.
Okay.
Okay, probably perfect.